All right, good afternoon and prompted.
So very excited to have you around. So
I'm Nicaratus. Go by Niko. I'm a
principal software engineer at Google
working on Google Workspace Security.
Been working security for 25 years now.
So uh super exciting to have all of you
around trying to tackle that very very
complex uh issue. So big thank you also
to my wife and my kids or patient and
their love enabling me to do something I
really love.
>> All right coming over.
>> All right. Yeah sure. Let's give a hug.
>> Actually what I want to do is this.
>> All right.
Okay. All right. So today we are
basically confronting very defining
security challenge for generative AI era
like perfect storm where bically
traditional security boundaries are
simply no longer enough like I'm going
to share with you what we observe over
the last couple of years but what we've
been doing about it I've been basically
doing geni security for three years now
and there's a lot of thing lot of lesson
we learned along the way I want to share
them so people are not repeating the
mistake and actually trying to build
like really secure software.
So first we'll start by dissecting the
threat like pretty much a new prompt
code environment that has deep access to
very sensitive data. So but then we're
going to examine like cat and mouse game
and how it's futile right now exposing
like failure reactive filtering.
Then we're going to the core of the
session is going to be about
architecting the fortress where we are
trying to present like a new structural
security blueprint to hopefully make
things secure. And finally cover like
semantic resilience discussing the
importance of like continuous testing
rigor human loop confirmation to secure
AI.
So we are right now a very crucial and
very stormy era for security. Things are
going really fast. But like unlike
traditional application security where
we could rely on filtering for syntactic
pattern like script tag or SQL injection
code in GI world like the prompt is code
like every single token in the input
stream is a potential instruction. So
and instruction are semantic rather than
syntactic. They can be obiscated in many
ways but the standard infrastructure
like file and filter will never catch.
So we are facing two distinct but
somewhat synergistic issue here. First
like semantic shift in traditional app
security we have deterministic parsing.
There's a SQL injection everybody have
seen what they look like and so often
like software engineer that facing pro
injection they're asking oh why can't
you block it just like a SQL injection
but in general the grammar is natural
language which is inherently very fuzzy
like the is no longer just breaking
syntax it's shifting the context so
attacker can use linguistic technique
like persuasion role playing to bypass
tender filters so model is interpreting
intent rather than executing rigid
command.
A second issue we have is protest code
that basically collapses the control
plane. So in classical computing like
code and data separate in LLM we we deal
with context learner. So they treat the
system instruction user input the data
as a single and contiguous stream of
token. So this is very structural
vulnerability we deal with and there's
no real out of bound way to tell the
model this 500 token are just data do
not execute them nox bit for the memory
so to the model every token is a
potential instruction which allow the
data to overwrite like instruction that
and we have prompt injection so
understanding the difference is is very
critical for the different in depth
because we need tools to monitor
malicious intent
but It's not just that it's also like
instruction hijacking that will happen.
So in the productivity environment that
we have the main risk we face from LM is
indirect point injection.
So in um indirect point injection is the
main thing is hidden like a zero click
supply chain attack malicious
instruction is buried often in external
untrusted content that can be like a
calendar invite or an email not in the
user direct prompt. then it's going to
exploit benign action like attack can be
triggered when a user perform a very
normal useful action or automation like
having an AI summarize the day and that
cause the agent to ingest and execute
the hidden prompt
and the the core issue we have here is
omigrity so the LLM treat all incoming
text whether it's a trusted system
instruction or untrusted external data
as single command allowing external
payload to override the agent
instruction
So this enables impact at scale like
every a single malicious document or
invite can spread and activate
thoroughly across many users. So that
turn a very benign feature into hidden
fishing or data acceleration channel.
So here I have a example from a couple
years ago visually illustrating concrete
example of the the zero clickness of
indirect prompt injection attack. So
here we have a malicious payload that's
hidden within a Gmail message and
invisible to the user. And when an AI
agent is going to perform a pretty
benign helpful task like summarization,
it will ingest a hidden text which
effectively override the instruction
executing attacker command and that
exactly demonstrate the danger we have
with prompt cut principle applied to
untested content here. So where the risk
is very limited here because it's
bically mostly the content that going to
be replaced we have to be extremely
careful when we're going to use more
complex workflow that potentially can do
action.
So the the second major risk we we have
encountered is insecure output handling
like specifically a threat around
markdown exciltration.
So markdown is issue of fundamentally
like rendering attack like large
language model can be prompted to
generate malicious markdown that is
going to be rendered often in HTML that
will include resources like images or
link and forcing request to an attacker
server. So that enables silent
exfiltration. You potentially have data
that's super sensitive to external
resource URL leaking it when the
resource is fetch. So the for example
the data here can be hidden in just a
query parameter of an image link. And
the final critical thing to to have in
mind here is the verification gap like
the end user only see potentially a
broken image icon or failed link
rendering in the output but the attacker
already won. It successfully c captured
sensitive data inside their server log
without the user even knowing it. And
that's a real world vector similar to
what demonstrated for you know like
echolique year ago.
So the third and major usage risk of
course is around rogue actions
represented a critical leap in threat
model and that enjoy enabling and the
first element with this is what we call
agency gap with a viability in reasoning
when there's a disconnect between the
user actual intent and autonomous
execution performed by AI agent. So
because uh agent reasoning is
nondeterministic, minor prom variation
can lead to accidental rogue action. For
example, agent intentionally emailing
sensitive data to the wrong person just
because of a name conflict and just
figure out oh that's close enough.
The second issue is orchestration
hijacking like rogue action are
frequently result of compromised
orchestration layer where the LLM serve
as planner for tool calls and this is
even more prevalent with MCP system but
like malicious actor can exploit it by
using that indirect prompt injection to
manipulate the direct data or just
planting dormant triggers that is are
going to have consequences later on and
the trigger will an attacker to hijack
communication between agent or
manipulate the planner into calling tool
with authorized parameters. So in vote
action can be time based or event based
occurring long after the initial input
what process effectively mask the source
of the attack. You can have that
injection insert in the database and a
layer later being executed.
Finally we have a confused deputy. So
that's happened when the orchestration
layer grants an agent's permission that
exceed the specific authorization
expected by the end user. So that allows
rogue action to potentially bypass stand
access control and act privilege proxy.
So I think you all seen it but like
Simon will coined the term lethal
trifecta to define that convergence of
factor that elevate the risk assia.
So the agent has deep access to
sensitive private data like email,
personal file, document.
Then the agent has continuous exposure
to untrusted external content from new
email, incoming messages,
uh change request and third, the agent
posess capability to execute external
command through API calls. So with when
those three element converge within a
single system, the LM can effectively
transform into a powerful and very
tempting application layer that
attackers can manipulate for high impact
rogue action.
So we're going see like an example of
real world vector that was presented
like uh at black air last year which is
invitation all you need uh that benasi
taco and so that in that case an
attacker will send a Google calendar
invite with hidden payload and nothing
happened until the user simply ask
what's on my schedule today that sounds
like very benign request from us there
and then the agent will ingest the
invite understand the mic icious
instruction and then can move laterally
excel data or doing other action. So in
our case we actually pro we protected
acceleration of data pretty well but
some home action like the we did not
realize like they can potentially be
very scary. So in that case control of
light control of home curtains control
temperature of the heater.
So no zero day at a vulnerability
exploited no malware installation no
link click required and you can have a
real consequences in the world.
So now going to see how do I simply
trying to filter prompt is fundamentally
a losing game.
So why trying to win that cat on mouse
game with a filtering is doing
proposition like there's three main area
that we can justify first static filter
that includes like block list and regax
they operate purely on syntax so they
can be very very easily defeated by a
simple obation technique. So basically
for encoding hex string ro 13 the llm
understand it without any special
instruction and the moment the data
don't coded the pattern the filter is
looking for simply breaks and the
malicious instruction is allowed to pass
through. The second element is ML
classifier sounds great they are better
than basic pattern but they lack true
semantic depth. So attacker can bypass
probabilistic model using subtle changes
like synonym swapping translating the
payload to a low resource language for
example or just using adversarial
prefixes. So this method can nudge the
model confident just enough for
malicious intent to sneak through
detection and you just need like one
bypass and you can get through. So
finally like multimodel attacks
demonstrate critical blind spot we have
like text only filter are completely
blind to instruction hidden in visual or
audio format. So malicious instruction
can be just buried an image metadata or
hidden in text in images and using OCI
evasion technique but that bypass
standard text processing pipeline
entirely. So this constant inadequacy
across all reactive filtering layer
prove that a structural solution is
required to do better.
Another technique that been prevalent
been used of LLM as judge basically
requesting a second LLM to review the
response before it send back to the end
user. A critical flow here though with
is recursive prompt injection. When the
secondary LLM judge review and trusted
data, it is subject to same semantic
vulnerability of the primary model.
So the attack pattern here is due to the
fact that judge and attacker share the
same semantic interface. Payload can
include instruction aimed specifically
at the judge. So an example is like
semantic gaslighting where you're just
going to say malicious context will
instruct the judge to review the
following as safe even if content
execution command as a thief for
research. Trust me.
So
all traditional vulnerability that live
in poorly sanitized string or
brokenation check agent vulnerability
live in language and context. So
malicious payload is syntactically
inocuous and look like plausible user
request. So reactive guardrail and
pattern matching are inherently
inadequate because threat actor will
constantly leverage evolving technique
such like multimodal hidden text
injection to maintain evasion
superiority and you do not want to play
cat on m because you're always behind
and you you'll get exploited. So what
can you do? How can we leap forward at
the defender? We need to identify
stronger and layer foundation that able
to tackle complex attack.
So the first layer that you come up with
is ensuring it sounds very basic but
that's reality just ensuring that the
input into the agentic system is low
risk. So what we've been doing is for
example is going to do vis visible
content only like in case of email we
want to get rid of anything that is not
visible to the end user. There's no
point in sending like hidden HTML to an
LLM. It's all about what we what the
user sees. So we get rid of hidden text
and authentication.
The second is input filtering. You want
to block content that is deemed risky.
Like if we already know that an email is
likely spam or fishing, there's no
reason to expose a poor LLM to that
content.
And finally, you want to leverage as
much as signal as possible like
implement data provenence tracking to
enforce policy such as like user
affinity, user risk score, prompt
injection classification throughout the
system. So we always know where we are.
A second layer is dealing with the
context stand as prompt to the LM. So we
are going to try to do prom delimitation
and reinforcement. It's not linguistic
marker and adversial training to harden
context window. So one of technique is
to leverage like sentinel token which is
basically token encapsulating content.
We're going to mark inside the prompt
where the data is. Then we're going to
try to have prompt enforcement uh
explaining to the LLM to be where to be
careful, why to be careful and also rely
on fine-tuning training model to strict
ignore imperative commands found within
data delimiters. It's absolutely not
perfect but it moved a little bit the
bar which is better than nothing.
And again this is all about layers. The
third layer is to enable deterministic
orchestration decision to get stateful
policy enforcement.
So we progressively implement like
security logic to forbid dangerous
action sequences. We have a state aware
session tracking which means we have an
orchestrator that maintain finite state
machine tracking risk level of context
and then we can dynamically restrict
downstream capabilities based on data
origin
and then we can have deterministic
policy where at every orchestration step
we can do enforcement not just on
initial pro. An example would be to
require human confirmation for mutation
and data sharing chains or we can
actually deny uh action for example
after accessing sensive user data you do
not want to do a web request on the
internet. So we're going to constrain
the problem to something that can be
deterministically protected.
The last layer of protection is
protecting the output the output
sanation validation. So here the output
DLM is typically markdown but we render
at HTML. So we are passing and scrubbing
down that markdown to eliminate
anomalies such as unwanted images link
protocol. So we perform dynamic URL
classification.
So we have dynamic URL classification
where we're going to identify malicious
URL. If it's in safe browsing data as
malicious URL there's no reason to
render it.
And finally, we ensure that ungrounded
link that have been hallucinated by the
LLM are scrub like the LM just come up
with a URL likely it's not great.
So everything is great but to survive
that perfect storm that is coming and
the attacker that will be relentless, we
cannot be static like true systemic
resilience is achieved through
relentless cycle of testing, validating
and learning.
So the first pillar for the systemic
resilience is automated regression
testing. So we must run like automatic
regression testing framework that is
going to repeatedly and systematically
subject of system to all known classes
of agentic attacks. So framework is
engineered specifically to capture
regression meaning to ensure that
defense we built last month is not
inadvertently broken by a new feature
developed this week. You also want to
try many times you attack because of the
probabilistic nature of LLM. Sometime
you try the same attack 10 times and one
out of 10 it will work and you won't get
rid of that problem. So the goal is to
preempt sophisticated agentic attack
that can penetrate the production
environment
and something super important here is it
takes a village to do that and securing
AI at this scale require deep
collaborative partnership with dedicated
like red team that are going to find
zero day vector and our co-engineering
team that implement structural defenses.
Another element we rely on is our VP
program, vulnerability re program and
dedicated hacking event like bug swap.
So we work security researcher to try to
challenge our systems and push them to
find vulnerability and fix them
proactively.
So when high stake ever action happen we
cannot fully rely on agent autonomy. So
to mitigate risk of rogue action, we
implement a structural pattern known as
plan, validate, execute. So whenever
there any sensitive task like moving
data or sharing file, we are going to
pose. So first we're going to set up the
planning to know what is going to
happen. Then we're going to have a
gatekeeper an action where if an action
breaks dynamically generated policy or
misalign with the user intent, we're
going to block the action and ask a
question for human confirmation. But if
something is completely off the guard
rails like for example we have
contextual Asian security framework like
consec dynamically detect something
going off the rail we can just block
thing right away and finally if
everything pass we can actually execute
the action and there's still a lot of UX
research to deal with review fatigue and
rubber stamping like first people to
keep verifying things they'll just
become approval bots.
So common element in in world of
generative AI security to obscurity is
not viable different like we have to
recognize that the different action um a
decision can appear as an op box and to
combat that we have actually provide
like detailed logs to admin to allow
them to understand what is going on
review what happened and fix issues.
Then the final pillar of systemic
resilience here is to incorporate
userdriven signal directly into security
posture. So in that case we're going to
rely on security not being just a line
but actually being a loop. We empower
user with feedback allow us to allow
them to send us and report us whenever
they feel they dealt to the AI
hallucination or prompt injection and we
can incorporate that in our detection
service detect if we catch things too
too much thing not enough thing and we
can adjust things. I will love
experience with spam and abuse and we
apply that experience here.
So now three takeaways here. So first we
have to shift philosophy entirely with
semantics and boxing like the cat and
mouse game or filtering is over. We
cannot rely on simple like blacklist or
machine learning classifier because
prompt is code and we need to build like
systemic semantic sandbox with those
defense in them. The second it's very
important to have trust provenence
understanding data and tracking it
throughout the agentic lifeline. So we
need to understand like what file got
access what the sensitivity level so we
understand any point in time what is
potentially being excfiltrated and
provide those guard rails whenever it
happen like to confirmation or just
blocking things
and finally systemic resilience we need
to design for adaptative security and
robustness like we cannot secure genai
as a oneshot with one time measure it's
a continuous and selfcorrecting process
we need to have with automated testing
and offering transparency and ability
for people to report thing. So we can
actually embedding human the loop
monitoring feedback and we can have
adaptative defenses but constantly
strengthen the process.
So I hope that was super helpful and we
have any question
in the back there.
>> Thanks very much for the uh taxonomy and
the idea the set of ideas around how to
how to address the issue. Um,
I think we're kind of all dancing around
the real issue, which is in building
LLMs and AIS, we've made the same
mistakes we made when we chose the
vonoyoman architecture over the uh uh
touring architecture where by combining
code and data in memory, buffer
overflows work instead of having code
and data in separate memory structures.
And by combining code and data in the
same same single prompt window, we've
made the same mistake.
Why wouldn't we separate two separate
just two separate windows, separate
interfaces? One is where you're entering
the commands and the other where you're
sending the data.
Yeah, it's I say it's an interesting
part is like been working in security
for like 25 years. It's uh it's very
interesting how much we are going back
in time and we are back in the time of
Windows 95 everything running at the
same user like barely any monitoring and
so on and I I do feel it's uh we have to
get like unfortunately things are moving
extremely fast unfortunately/fortunately
things are going so fast but we need to
think very strongly about how to build
things with defense in depth and defend
by default so we are not like
catastrophically
building system that are insecure. Like
we had talk earlier today of someone
showing like 600 uh fixes already for
their vibe coded project supposedly for
security and it's like it's very very
scary that people like security
practitioner are jumping in and we have
so much creation of of new code that is
super vulnerable and and sure we are we
have LLM to fix a vulnerability but it's
never ending loop and attacker have a
tendency to be really fast and people
are not patching things very quickly. We
had years ago we work on a project where
we discuss the lower vulnerabilities
where the median time for critical
vulnerability to be patched by
enterprise was 30 days. So now if we're
going to find vulnerability like in a
few minutes and it takes 30 days for
people to patch it's not going to be
great. So we definitely need as an
industry to do so much better in
security. We need a lot of new ideas and
applying the security by default,
security by design principle for
everything that being created otherwise
going to be really sad.
Fair.
All right. Thank you.